a piece of news that uh
that updates a story we spent a lot of
time on this morning on pft live the
nfl's memo from last night
making it clear to all the teams not
that the nfl needed to that players who
work out away from the facility even if
they're working out to stay in football
shape
if they get injured and it's serious
the team doesn't have to pay them that
in my estimation was a middle finger to
the union because the union's been
agitating for players to not work out at
the team facility
and it was a message to the players hey
you better work out at the team facility
and if you do you're covered your
surgery gets paid for you get your
salary you have other benefits available
to you
so tom pelicero of nfl media and it's
interesting that they would leak this to
a guy who works for the league
but tom pelicero of nfl media has a memo
that was sent to the players today they
met with board of player representatives
yesterday
and from the phone call there were some
highlights and the one that really
stands out to me
is that uh and and i'm going to read
this directly from
the email we discussed the nfl's memo
relating to the injury suffered by one
of our brothers this week the nfl has
never ever sent such a memo about
voluntary workouts which is confirmation
that your position is both right and
effective
it was gutless to use a player's serious
injury as a scare tactic
to get you to come running back to these
workouts this memo
is yet another sign of what they think
of you and also affirms that they simply
want to control you
year round in any and every way
that they can that that is a lot of huff
and puff
they ain't gonna blow anybody's house
down with it though because here's the
bottom line
juwan james if he would have suffered a
torn achilles tendon
at the team facility we wouldn't be
having this conversation
he'd get his 10 million dollars he'd be
eligible
for all of the other benefits that
become available now they say in this
memo
we've been in touch with juwan james
despite the ongoing threat
and the open threat of an nfi
designation juwan was working out to
stay in shape under a program
recommended to him by his coach
i don't care about that you're not
working out at the team facility
you got to be working out of the team
facility you know what they're going to
argue that because he was doing what the
coach said you should do at home
that that somehow that somehow counts as
being
at an extension the team facility i i
don't get it and if that's their point
that should have been the lead of the
memo not buried near the bottom of it i
i don't think there's an argument to be
made that juwan james
is not going to be at risk of losing at
serious risk of losing that money so
look they got to do what they got to do
i get it they staked out a difficult
position that never made much sense to
me
and and now that they they can the only
reaction is you know what they say in
the law when the law
or when the law's on your side pound on
the law when the facts are on your side
pound on the facts when neither is on
your side pound on the table
this is just some pounding on the table
by the union because i don't think
there's anything else they can really
say
well right and i think you wrote this
mike that there's precedent for what
this situation is it goes
all the way back to 1977 so it's not
like this is something that is brand new
for the players for the union for teams
for contracts in any situation like that
so
and even so you know you want to talk
about what was collectively bargained
and that's the off-season program the
voluntary off-season program that guys
do not have to go to
right so that is just what that is but
i think if you're talking about injury
protections like i said it
this is not something that's new so it's
really interesting to me
just how this is going to play out
between the league and the union because
it feels like it's a battle that the
union can't really win
and i always talk about this like you
know you got to pick battles that you
can win and i don't know
what winning looks like for the pa in
this particular case
because i i just don't know how they're
going to get there mike
and and look i have always supported
player causes
and it always upsets me that fans will
align with the billionaires over the
players whenever something like this
goes down when there's a
potential work stoppage when there's a
fight and we have highlighted in the
past situations where the union has
caught the league with its hand in the
cookie jar on certain calculations and
i i i've got a clear record
of supporting the players and i'm easy
to find
if there really is an argument to make
that juan james is going to get his
money
tell me get come on record come on the
show i they they
i i know those folks and i i just i
think this was an opportunity
by players who are in positions of union
leadership
to vent their frustrations about what
happened last year
and the miscalculation was made that
this was harmless it's not harmless
when a guy blows out and achilles tendon
and he's going to be out 10 million
dollars
or more for 2021 and may end up never
playing again in the nfl because the
broncos are likely going to say we
voyager guarantees
see you later and we move on hi i'm mike
tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports